and sometimes
me too
ok
aww
No
let me just
hey
I
right
Oh
Oh
not
honey white one
what
Oh
so
what
oh yeah
we have to
did
you
one
Oh
locate
five
Oh
Oh
I will now read out the emergency
evacuation notice should we be required
should we be required it's not working
at fault ok I just switched him on ok
let give it a minute and it will so
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building by the nearest available exit
to the chamber our assembly point will
be in the public car park at the side of
the Civic sweet please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please note that this
meeting will be audio recorded please be
upstanding for the chairman of the
council the Chairman's chaplain and the
chief executive
good evening everybody and welcome to
the annual meeting of what the district
transferred but will you please remain
silent while I introduce myself in and
then and cause the chief executive of a
amar and what could be about here
tonight and the first thing I'd like to
do is to ask you Allen to say a prayer
please Thank You Heather and may I just
say it's really good at you to turn out
and Tottenham Hotspurs colors tonight or
maybe not I'm going to tell you story
and I don't leave you know it's about
two hundred twenty-one days to Christmas
did you know ok perhaps didn't wanna
know this is a Christmas story that mrs.
Jones a teacher was very curious about
how each of our students celebrated
Christmas so she called on young Patrick
Murphy she said tell me Patrick what are
you doing Christmas time well Patrick
addressed the class he said well mrs.
Jones me and my 12 brothers and sisters
go to the midnight mass and we sing
hymns then we come home very late we put
mince pies by the back door and hang up
our stockings then all exciting go to
bed and wait for father Christmas to
come with all our toys very nice Patrick
she said now Jimmy Brown what do you do
Christmas well mrs. Jones me and my
sister also go to church my mum and dad
and we sing carols and we get home ever
so late we put cookies and milk by the
chimney and we hang up our stockings we
hardly sleep waiting for Santa Claus to
bring our presents now realizing that
there was a Jewish boy in the class and
not wanting to leave him out of the
discussion she asked now isaac cohen
what do you do at Christmas for more
Isaac replied well it's the same thing
every year you know dad comes home from
the office we part into the rolls-royce
then we drive to his toy factory when we
get inside we look at all the
empty shelves and begin to sing what a
friend we have in Jesus and then we will
go on holiday to the paramus okay let's
pray Almighty God creator sustainer and
Redeemer of the world hear our prayers
tonight during this Pentecost season and
the coming of the holy spirit that
brought into being the birth of the
church we continue to ask for guidance
and wisdom tolerant attitudes and
understanding in all our dealings to all
that we serve in our communities help us
to be fair minded and open loving our
neighbor and prepare to go the extra
mile and show acts of kindness without
favor may your blessing be upon this new
council of Rochford district and all who
have been elected and those who have
served and I'm no longer in public
office with particular thanks Brad
chairman Heather gleam and her long
years of service let our yes be yes and
our no be no and our friendships in jira
and enhance our lives together working
for mutual benefit and we also pray for
this torn world were injustice and
conflict rage asking for strength and
desire to live in harmony and peace to
end suffering and live as human beings
with the highest honor and integrity and
the blessing of God Almighty the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit remain with
us now and always Armand thumbs up thank
you for we found you and of course of
the year young man thank you very much
young man going thank you very much and
please really want to sit down please
before the meeting connected any louder
you're all wondering why I'm standing
here with a hat on my head amount of
people that do not only of none of all
the hat right over here for all things
have gone through but the main reason
I'm wearing a hat tonight is that when i
became district councillor 26 years ago
and do you want to sit down before I
statement thank you it's a squeeze and
it's not in it
my carry-on when I became the district
council here in 1990 1994 and I came to
the first meeting all the ladies present
perhaps it'll be nasty press and all the
new members and old members every member
had a suit on and the district help sort
I and today i'm wearing my part from 26
years ago the council changed
tremendously people have changed
tremendously that I just wanted to go
out in the same way as I came in all
those years ago thank you very much
item one direction of Tim of the council
for 99 and 2000 16 17 for this municipal
year-long hiatus tree councillor chapel
Thank You chairman thank you for all the
work you've done this year it's great to
see you all dressed up nice for the
council you know preview that entirely
can I say someone who serve discounts
which were quite some years now I think
he's got time that she had flirt the
Chairman and I'm sure she'll make an
expert Jim I would like to know I our
West thank you very much man have a
second Good Counsel Specter ex-chairman
yes give me great pleasure to nominate
Carol which is there any other
nominations count your flight thank you
i travel at speeds nomination i would
agree that cowls have a good choice she
has been on the council quite a while
she's certainly way to the turn and
actually make a good chairman or share
the council and a slightly with my
members me numbers as well but it isn't
simply a role of servo neither side is
very important as you know them there
was more to being trimmed the ceremonial
role and that's it having Constitution
you can find it the article 5 I won't
breathe a whole lot of fighting it sets
out other judges for training including
item 3 which says to ensure that the
council meeting is a form from the basic
matters of concern to local community
and the place of which members who are
not in the executive or whole committee
chairmanships are able to hold the
members of executive and committee trim
into account that's one of the roles and
I'm sure how I'll do a better job of
that thank you Mike thank you very much
can't sit down place that actual piece
don't get up I know it you're indisposed
as far as standing up and I'm only too
pleased and my armor not for everybody
else wish you were Thank You chairman I
wish I could stand but it isn't advised
at the moment so thank you so much for
that and I hope that Carol will allow
the same privilege to me I would have
been happy to second Carol counselor
western for chair of the council because
I to have the greatest respect for the
work she's done over a long period of
time I certainly recall how well she
chaired the central area committee for
two years I i believe and it was a very
appropriate and very very lively but an
extremely fair chairmanship and I'm
absolutely sure cancel black has to say
about that will be delivered because I
have seen it in practice think you want
so thank you very much thank you about
anybody else wish to say anything
general would you buy will agree that
this nomination is it it's accepted I
have a show of hands please it's a grief
pitiful everybody thank you very much
Carol with the right to come up
can I put this on you and I hope you
have a good a year as ipad and all the
work that you've been in the past now
come to fruition and wherever you go
you'll be very well welcome because
you're Rochford congratulations hi
Caroline Western have you been elected
to the office of chairman of the Council
of the District of Rochford declare that
I take that off this upon myself and
will Julie and faithfully fulfill the
duties of it according to the best of my
judgment and ability I undertake to
observe the code after the Condor which
is expected members of Watford District
Council
before I carry on may I take this
opportunity of thanking our past
chairman next district councillor mrs.
heather glen for the years she has
dedicated herself as a district
councillor for Oxford I would like to
say it has been my privilege to have
been associated with heather has been an
inspiration to me and I expect too many
other councillors and members of the
public header on behalf of the
counselors may I present you with this
small token from X calculus and each
other I can only say for the wonderful
color well absolutely wonderful surprise
and thank you all very very much and it
will go somewhere invites very small
garden and I will try to get my
son-in-law I'm not to mow it down but
capable and to you new people are
starting tonight it's going to be a
wonderful year you've got lots of things
to come and I'm going to laugh at laugh
at you all because I will hardly sit in
my garden and watch it a cat one of my
cats eating a squirrel that's something
fun isn't it died as you saw it Oh God
ounce of lead that have a wonderful year
and thank you so very much you need
thank you I'm now going to present to
the the part chain and the badge
I've got one now members now have to
vote collection of vice chairman for the
ensuing year have our piece of the
nomination to cut more Thank You
chairman someone who's been a council
member for quite some years now as
chaired the audit committee extremely
well end up committees has been a loyal
servant counselor I'm sure she'll make
an extremely good vice chairman that's
council mrs. levy butcher thank you
gentlemen have a second thanks Janet
gives me great pleasure to second that
nomination to learn more any other
nomination containers is that agreed by
the body please shouting angrily thank
you very much councillor
excuse me catalyst I'd like to elect
invest Leslie push it as vice chairman
I've got the council
thank you everybody I'm Leslie ambrosia
hadn't been elected to the office of
vice chairman at the Council of the
District of Rochford declare that I take
that top is a calm myself and will Julie
and faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
abilities I undertake to observe the
code as to the conduct which is expected
of members of the Rochford District
Council
2000 can attract new looking at a later
date
I not be on the stage to receive a
project for absence Thank You chairman
we have apologies in the office from
kelso Carter thank you number seven
minutes of the meeting held in lighting
the rightful 2016 oh great announcements
of a 10 ounces for the chairman and or
head of gray services there are none
number 93 let the leader of accounts for
year 2016-17 municipal year mayor happy
nominations please that's a step back
thank german i just be my pleasure to
nominate counselor to total how I sit
for the second degrees happy future to
second faster too are there any more
nominations are we all in agreement
cancer come on Tyson Thank You chairman
um it's very nice to be able to be
leader again for this munis premier I'm
sure if you're challenging year for all
of us and not just because of the budget
of many other things as well I do hope
that we can all work together on these
things and to make sure that we actually
do the best for the people of Rochford
does that in the end is what we are
working for thank you Jim thank you
can't come
Peggy chairman firstly chairman the
leader of the council is invited to the
nails executive portfolio and associated
appointees degrees in general thank you
very much Jimmy Gemini a pleasure in
announcing the problem for photo holders
as deputy leader councillor NJ steptoe
portfolio community is capsular mrs. jl
only the portfolio enterprise counselor
jim JT IMO shots at everyone's all dogs
do the work oh and you want to you are
the authority my apologies for
environment councillor DJ sparing
counselor finance is counselor songsmith
ESP Smith for governments account
services Cheryl Roshi road at the
Planning Council in ward council a 4
that's it
thank each area secondly the political
composition of the carousel should be
reflected in the allocation of seats on
the council committees and subcommittees
the appendix attached to the report that
page is 12.5 and 12.6 show street
allocations based on the current
composition in accordance with the
proactive lewis council's asking the
doors the attendance which would be the
chief officer appointments can see the
planning policy subcommittee chairman
daughter remember being door / we thank
you James thirdly good leaders to be
invited to nominate councils committees
and the subcommittee based on the cover
of the arrangement just agreed I to 12
addendum wall bracket revised bracket
the most recently issued document so
it's item 12 addendum 1 revised in
brackets commencing on page twelve point
seven sets out the membership committees
and subcommittees but they would be
taking on water nomination to see and
that documents for endorsement the
Liberal Democrat blue has indicated that
it doesn't wish to take up one of the
sinks which isn't art among the youth
meeting page 12.9 of addendum 1 revised
with cancelled agreements a member from
another group all along group member may
be appointed to this vacancy a
nomination has been made by the green
and Rockford discreet residents group
how to cut off Thank You chairman
chairman I'll ever notice that Jamie
burger castle Jamie Burton because he is
a one-man man so as to speak he's not in
any crew he's a non-aligned member has
no place on any committee and it would
seem to me that on the review committee
it would be an ideal place because it's
a place where there is the challenge to
the council and the executive that would
be an ideal place for him to six so is
it in order I asked through our officers
to provide a nominating to position on
that review committee chairman that
would be in order what it mean is that
we've got we would have two nominees for
one vacant seat so there would need to
be a show of hands in respect of each of
those if Kelsey Burton was included
you have to fight your fights I've got
to get to know your names in your faces
absolutely Thank You children i'd like
to withdraw my nomination to a counselor
be to say thank you very much channel in
that case councillors agreed with review
committees councillor Burton would like
to see that great members very lucky
chap mr. that includes concludes
appointments to committees and the
subcommittee the balance being asked by
paper finally nominations epirus 300
leaders for the appointment of chairman
and vice-chairman of committees of a
subcommittee these are set out at
addendum to bracket revised bracket
which is the most recent paper pages 20
point 11 and 20 point 12 and that's for
endorsement the chairmanship of the
review committee falls to any member of
the Council who's not a member of the
majority group there are two nominations
for the one position councillor michael
hawaii and council hook way chairman in
that case it would be about inviting a
show of hands for each of those nominees
that's a bummer
Thank You chairman in the same spirit
that we nominated the capsule Jamie
Burton to be a member of lab review
committee it would sing to us on this
side of his house that he would make an
ideal review committee chairman because
he's not online to any party whatsoever
is a truly independent member so my
group would like to nominate counts to
Jamie burden this chairman of the review
committee in addition to the other
nominations Thank You chairman at the
current time that would been the cows is
a position where there are three
nominees each of which we voted on by a
show of hands against her counsel mr.
procedure that's left black thank you I
wish to speak to the nominations run a
little bit of confusion too much because
so but isn't going to have to link with
Drew and emotion from the new commercial
what didn't make that for the message
she actually felt the Chancellor counsel
at Newcastle weekly water Schoenberg
would be a suitable person to be on
review committee Lewis lunch price when
he declined the offer so I'm in the
state's introducing the moments about
supporting him the chair for terms with
your always supporting another Pender to
nothing thank you can supply
thank you madam chairman and bassist
that fer this throughout the candidates
are dirt likes withdraw my nomination
thank you very much have a quick package
em there are there for two nominees for
one championship could I please invite a
show of hands for counselor Michael
Hawaii thank you now could I invite a
show of hands for counselor third
Jim castle Burton is the electric chair
of the review committee thank you
finally shown in terms of this paper
there are two nominations to the vice
challenge in under standards committee
castle trade connecting again chairman
it'd be a question of a shell pounds in
respective each candidate chairman
through you could I please invite us
show of hands for Cassadine
thank you and now pass directly please
chairman on that basis Kelso Dre the
vice chairman of the status of the
reintegration three measurements for
team captain meeting to prove the sugary
of meetings of the council on the
following day approve member 15
appointment of representatives to
actually authorities and other forums
2016-17 huggy chairman turn 3 2015 in
terms of desire to make the procedures
set out at page 15.3 eight and twelve so
that page 15.3 it's got seven
recommendations the first recommendation
this one's an officer and portfolio
others without slide bodies for 2016-17
be on the basis set out appendix wallet
report that's on page fifteen point five
that's the first artists to agree to a
great fortune
Thank You chairman the second
recommendation is that member
representatives including substitutes be
appointed in the 2016-17 year to the
outside bodies at appendix to the report
the named bodies and nominees was
perceived as set out on pages 15.8 and
50.9 of attending one endorsement
perform of these bodies more nominations
have been received than there are
seeking these are the hockey community
center association london Southend
Airport consultative committee the
rugged Range Community Association
governing body relate south ethics and
rocks with and rayleigh CA B that's 45
the bodies so we turn to our 215
addendum one with the nominees the first
problem we deal with is the hockey
community center Association run at the
moment for three nominees the two seats
10 as previously will be about the show
Penny's for each of the nominees
that's a marsh McCoy thank you venture
it's a query facility of the now some
reason and I hope its right place to
raise it for the Rockford Housing
Association both we are showing three
appointees historically that has always
been poor places and I've seen nothing
in any paper cover say during really not
done to check this figure that that's
haven't changed if this will come white
has been just a 30 be chairman we will
be picking up that body bit bit later in
reports unadvised this afternoon but it
is for appointees until December of this
year so when we get to that item it
would be appropriate as we've got four
nominees to suggest that they would be
the appointing the closest appointees
and at this point until to December is
working the fibrous afternoon
boom
Toki chairman so turning to the poultry
community center Association we have
three nominees for two seats good line
by to show homes forecaster Carter
please
and I'm going to show parents to counsel
Hazelwood please
could I watch a show of hands for castle
eggs please
lucky charm on that basis councillors
Carter and Hazelwood of issues
appointees to the Association just threw
you chairman I just asked the officer I
noticed the koorivar fermented I'm
becoming to say Corrine our meat will
trust has two nominees on there for one
place should be an obvious shark answer
the question Thank You chairman correct
but thank you so perhaps you bleep terms
the quarry environment trust
alphabetically the earlier one next
we've got nominations two nominations
for one seat we've got counselor mrs.
Weston counselor EADS again it would be
a question of show of hands for each
candidate could I please invite chopin's
for counsel western energy
Oh
please invite his show pens for
counselor Yves Thank you Thank You
chairman councillor Westin is the
appointee is Corey environment of trust
next week's over to the London Salford
airport it's a song dear come on just
put the clarification [ __ ] and the next
one down is actually nice hot foot
Medford online is that the game we have
to dominate for one place should we not
be helping each other Thank You chairman
I guess we should deal with that on next
thank you so the Essex partnership flood
management we've got two nominees for
one seat cassis fairing and castor
wilson put a house show of hands
forecaster sparing please
but show heavens for Costa Wilson please
well that place is cursed espero is the
appointee next body in London after
their call consultative committee we've
got five nominations for three seats
again chairman will be about sharp ends
could we please have a show of hands for
counselor Lucas Gill thank you
you please have a show of hands
forecasters step
could you please have a show of hands
for counselor mrs. Weston thank you
please have a show parents for foster
Elliot Mayson painting
thank you could you please have a show
has forecast little plane thank you
Thank You chairman on that faces
counselors little-scale steptoe & mrs.
Weston of appointees to the airport
Posadas committee the next body is the
road range community association
chairman that's back thank you with
regard to providing loans Community
Association I will be voting for
counseling this is lovely and council
announces their walk members
historically one or two operations we
have supporting board members they
thinking Thank You Castle black after
chairing so we have three eliminations
with two suits could we have a show of
hands for council this is lovely please
we will show up and spit closest bearing
please
could we have a show of hands for castle
amount into these
on that basis chairman calcis mrs.
Lumley and sparing other qualities chair
the next body is relate south essex we
had two nominees for one seat
councillors music scooting I'm sister
Sarah could I please advise nominations
a counselor mrs. pudding thank you
like these got nominations for custom
mrs. Besant thank you
on that basis calcium's is gooding is
the council's pointage Thank You
chairman moving on through the reports
recommendation 3 on page 15 points three
astronauts in orbit jet soil all the
breaks fittings and excuse me not
standing so if you agree that rochford
andreas advice bureau money BTW you
shown as one point t with to nominate
has it changed him yep no children that
one needs to be both you dog wash our
hands so we have two nominees for one
seat just as you wanted mr. Cassar could
you please have a show of hands for
Casper darling thank you
who with Vito Chopin's Patel swim season
south thank you
so therefore G is counselor yawning
Thank You Jonah hoping I'm safe to move
to recommendation 38 report that's
inviting council to endorse the
attendance of legal counsel all n
dominate to a number of external
partnerships happy Harry Potter thank
you doing chairman I must say what we
did have somebody in mind for a rock
without association board had it been 40
maybe realize it was only three so we
had this tonight if you like but as that
you've only just heard about it we do
have a 4th nominee and I would like to
nominate somebody who's a former
counselor here do I think we make an
extremely good member only watch the
Housing Association doesn't have to be
against the nation so I'd like to make
Chris nothing much second letter
council can we have our degrees of the
recommendation street plz sub agreement
that means Thank You chairman get
traditionally leader the council in
terms of a role in leader plays attends
specified qualities with with partners
who identified earlier on in the report
is tipped about endorsing that activity
chair
calculating I was having a cro-magnon
Kevin to the gospel association board
Please Please on each other panels
donation mr. Chris lovely football that
makes point nobody's for four places
yes chillin recommendation form of the
report relates to the rock regarding
association board there are currently
four seats to be appointed to and we now
have five nominees for four seats so
again your question of sharp ends in
respect of each nominee could I like
nominations for canceling thank you Jim
my voice is called a bit fun community
the office are pleased with the list of
the moniez because just behind four
subtypes not working Thank You chairman
the nominees are counselor Your Honor
counselor mrs. lonely counsel award
counselor Cooper and counselor mr. Chris
Lummi Antonia sorry too tight mr. Kris
Longley perspective perhaps yes and
Islamic
okay so you could have a show of hands
who can slit your own Ethan please
could I have a show of hands for Cal
slip which is lovely please could I have
a show of hands for counsel award please
could I have a show of hands for
counselor Cooper please
the finally could I have a show of hands
mr. Kris Longley please
Thank You chairman on that basis council
you are low calcium mrs. Lumley council
of war concert music so i feel mr. crisp
lovely other councils appointed chairman
telling to recommendation five of the
report council's us to police report of
the portfolio holder involvement
community safety to the police and crime
panel and the nomination by the
portfolio holder of a substitute endorse
good even to attend recommendation six
chairman that the appointment of the
portfolio holder involved with community
safety to the essex county wide for
every unit and the nomination by the
portfolio holder and the substitute be
endorsed
finally Chairman recommendation seven
for the portfolio holder involvements
highways and a further four
representatives be appointed to the
local highways panel the nominees set
out on page 15 point 10 of addendum 1
and those five nominees for the five
employers Chairman's so if that's agreed
that would conclude this report is that
green members very amazing german up
conclusion before Thank You mr. members
this meeting is now closed we'll all
invitee with potato chamber you are
invited to assemble in room for four
light refreshments thank you